- On this episode, Chase.
- This guy.
- Visits me.
(uptempo music)
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 154
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
- Show.
- [Both] Show.
- Chase why don't you
tell the Vayner Nation,
I know many of them know who you are.
As a matter of fact,
a lot of people that watch
this show discovered me
when you hosted me instead
of what we're doing now,
me hosting you.
Why don't you do a quick
little 90-second wrap
of who you are, shorty.
- Shorty, photographer, artist,
been that my whole life.
About four years ago started
a company called Creative Live
with my friend, Craig.
Now it's the largest
livestreaming education company
in the world.
- Incredible.
- We reach millions of
people all over the globe.
That's my main focus right now,
still making stuff.
Now trying to help other
people around the world
make their stuff
in photography, design, filmmaking.
Make a life as an entrepreneur.
- Where'd you grow up?
- Grew up in Seattle,
parents super middle class.
My dad was a cop,
my mom was an administrator
in a biotech company.
Grew up playing sports.
Was conflicted as a creative
because I was also a jock
and those things didn't go together.
- Back then.
- Back then,
now it's everybody.
- Now creatives are cooler.
Being like a jock in high school,
outside of certain parts, it's crazy
at least on the coast now,
you're like in fifth place.
Pretty interesting times.
- Skateboard culture
actually helped me put those
two things together
because super creative.
I grew up as a skate punk grom
and built a career that I
wanted more than anything.
- Why don't we link up,
I think in YouTube.
Let's give some love to the
interview I did with you.
Why don't you tell
everybody about that series
and what you did there.
You're apart of a double header today.
Yes, first time ever
#AskGaryVee Show double header.
I just had my father-in-law here.
Different speed,
my father-in-law is an
old school marketer.
Best dude,
that was a fun episode.
Super fun.
- Two in one day?
- Two in one day.
I'm putting them up the same day.
No like taping,
no changing.
Got this.
I got meetings until 12 tonight.
I got plenty.
The show you're doing is so incredible
and I want to siphon as
many people watch this
to make sure they're watching your thing.
- Started a show also about five years ago
about the same time we
watched Creative Live
called Chase Jarvis Live.
I turned down a bunch of
network opportunities to do.
- Your own thing.
- And a lot of that stuff.
They all didn't understand it,
didn't want to do it right.
- The economic deal sucked shit.
Gary do tv.
Sure get paid
no nothing, great.
- Short story too long already.
Started producing it out of
my photo studio in Seattle.
Inviting people I thought were great
and doing cool shit
and driving culture.
Not just digital culture,
but photographers, filmmakers,
guys like this turkey.
- A turkey.
- Folks like Macklemore,
Adrian Grenier from Entourage.
Doing interesting things.
People that are super famous
and also people that you've never heard
who were just grinding
away doing cool shit.
Just basically bringing creativity
and those folks to the internet.
- I think my interviews
is one of the great shows
in the history of your show.
- For sure.
- The best I would say.
- Surprise, you polled.
I got something from you people
about I think it's between this show
or this show.
- Best interviews, right?
- You were your best.
- 100 percent.
You and The Blaze.
Will Blaze, right?
- The Blaze.
I think a lot of people
voted for The Blaze.
I don't know who the.
- Go ahead, we curse.
- So do I.
I thought you were at
your best on my show.
- You know what's
interesting about your show?
- Let's go.
- I'm my fattest.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is that why people don't like it?
Is that why they rated
it second to The Blaze.
- The Blaze he did a great job.
Look go watch it, dick.
Don't judge it.
- It's very, very good.
- But I've lost 27 pounds since then.
- You look great.
- Thank, man.
That's what I was fishing for.
- For real.
- I appreciate it.
India, let's
get into.
- [Gary and Chase] The show.
- [Gary] Alright, let's do it India.
- [India] Alright Malik
has so many good questions.
- Malik listen he's a beast.
He gets on the show a bunch, Chase.
- [Voiceover] Malik asked,
"If I pursue what I think is my passion,
"but don't come close to
achieving what I want,
"will I have wasted my time?"
- Go Chase.
You can ask it again.
- One more time.
- [Voiceover] Malik asked,
"If I pursue what I think
"is my passion, but don't
come close to achieving
"what I want,
"will I have wasted my time?"
- No because there's really
only one thing in life
is doing exactly.
- The Jets, sorry go ahead.
- Which is doing exactly what
you're supposed to be doing.
That doesn't come from out here.
I've lived this exact problem.
I did what everybody else wanted me to do
for the first chapter of my life.
- Who was that?
That your parents?
- The world.
- I agree,
the market,
the market.
- Supposed to be a doctor, a lawyer
or in some shit or something else
and I literally.
- Guys by the way who
are watching were old.
Back then doctor lawyer was like.
- You're so smart.
- Doctor, lawyer.
- Yeah, respect.
- When's the last time an 18 year old
now is like you should be a doctor
or a lawyer.
That's like.
- That profession is
going to run out of people
to do the work.
- It's insane.
That just took me to such a weird place.
You should be a doctor
or a lawyer
or an accountant.
Accountant was in the mix.
- That was the list.
My parents were amazingly supportive.
This didn't really come from my parents.
But just culturally that's where.
- Your friend's parents
were sort a son of a bitch, right.
I fucking hate the friends' parents.
- The counselor at school.
- I never went to my
guidance counselor, ever.
Four years of high school,
never went.
- They don't know shit.
They're living in a different era.
I don't want to disrespect those folks.
- I disrespect different era.
- Different era.
That being said I serve somebody else
for a long time.
Emotionally mentally
even trying to reconcile
being an artist and athlete.
That was because
I was paying attention
with the culture wanted for me.
But that's all bullshit.
There's only one thing.
- Go ahead.
Get them both.
- You're right there.
There's only one thing.
You doing what you're supposed
to be doing in the world.
You can pay your dues.
I have a lot of respect for working hard,
digging ditches,
doing stuff to survive.
Practicality you call it.
But let's be real,
you have to do the things that's in here.
Otherwise you're just burning time.
- I'm going to throw
in addition, yes.
In addition.
- You always say yes
and that's what you're supposed to do.
- Is that the improv thing?
- Yes, yes.
- No but I will say this.
(laughter)
Countercultural Mike.
Mike is just my fake name
for general people.
Self-awareness.
My big thing
more than anything is
do not live on regret.
So I definitely am also on team
being happy will always trump more money
at the end at the end at the end.
So I try to play that way.
Luckily for me mine collided together.
But if you know you.
And you know like money like money.
Like money.
Like you just are obsessed by money.
Then maybe you should do the thing
that makes you the most money
because you wouldn't sit there one day
and say damn I wish I was an artist.
Now if you're the other way.
- That's like this in here
and you have to be honest
what you want to be.
Do you want to be a needlepoint expert.
But you want to make 10 million dollars.
- That's fake.
- Those two things don't go together.
So you've got to be real.
- I mean it's self-awareness
like a reverse engineer
yourself to not have regrets.
Having regrets in your
70s, 80s and 90s
is literally to me the worst thing
that can happen in life for sure.
- What's the asker's name?
- Malik.
- Malik, seriously
in here.
The answers are all in here.
- Chase I will say this though
and this is something
I've spent a lot of time
with the show on.
- Are we really going to go here?
- Yes.
- Ok.
- I do believe that you
and I got lucky
by having self-awareness
and emotional intelligence isn't you know.
- It's the new black.
- For sure.
By the way.
It's always been the black.
It's just being put front and center.
- For sure.
I just want to make sure
we're giving practical advice
saying like follow from what's in here.
I have family members who
literally have no fucking idea
what's in here.
I know them cold.
They have no idea.
- That's actually thing one is
you've got to figure it out.
And the way they figure out
is to live your life,
get in adventures
and do stuff.
- You know what.
I'm so on that.
Test and learn
between 20 and 30 to me is hot.
I'm hot on this idea
that if you really want to live
the best life you can live.
The new game plan is from 20 to 30 test
a lot of things
because the downside
the risks
you could go risky.
You've got bigger upside than downside.
- Classic Richard Branson.
Mitigate the downside.
That's literally why Creative Live exists.
So you can take thousands classes
from the world's best people.
And you can literally dabble.
And it's not just dabble
in community college,
you're taking it from
Pulitzer Prize winner,
New York Times bestseller,
this guy.
Smart, smart people.
Get you hands dirty.
- We're going to use for 17 hours
Let's go, India.
(inaudible)
- Sorry, yeah.
- [India] From Alan.
- Alan, do
you know Aj's name
is Alan Jack?
- [India] Really?
- Yeah call AJ Alan.
- In third grade he said he was Alan.
[India] One L, one A.
- In third grade
AJ said call me Alan.
That lasted for a couple months.
He's back to AJ.
Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] Alan asked
"Would you rather time travel
"100 years into the past
"or 100 years into the future
"and why?"
- Past, I would
make so much fucking bank.
I'd buy the Jets for $10,000 in 1963
and I'd be good.
(inaudible)
- I'll make fucking money, India.
- I'm just saying.
- Everything on the planet.
- Please not even close.
- This is Gary.
[India] I don't know if I'll admit that.
- Admit what?
- [India] He didn't mean
to see in the future.
- You didn't mean that Alan,
got it.
[India] I think Alan mean
you can see in the future.
- I tricked you I said
with what you know now,
you said yes.
- Emotionally we were talking about.
- Get out of here.
I know you bullshit.
Alright, let's
take a step back.
If you don't know anything
and you land
and you don't know anything,
you didn't know that you did that,
I would go to the future only
because I right now as a human
know what happened over the last 100 years
and the upside is not knowing.
- I put my answer through
the exact same filter.
If I know everything I'd go backwards
and do some really powerful shit.
Don't know anything go forward
and send me to the future.
- I'd be like this Microsoft
company feels right.
(laughter)
- This is interesting.
- I like this.
I like this governor in Arkansas.
I bet he's going to be president.
I would just kill it.
People are going to be
like Nostradamus.
I'd be crushing.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Vlad asked,
"dear Gary, in episode 122 you
say at 22 to 24 don't settle.
"What is the settling age?
"I thought you should never settle?"
- That's so weird
that's so funny.
- That's coming right from
something he told you.
- Yes, yes.
What's interesting is
we just talked about it
though how I just said from 20 to 30
that's funny that's interesting timing.
I think first of all I
think every goddamn answer
on this show
has to be very personal meaning,
if you and your boyfriend or girlfriend.
Have a baby when you're both seventeen
because that's what happened in your life
practicality enters your world.
- Casey I was just at Casey's.
- That's exactly right.
Practicality comes knocking.
What's up man practicality here.
You're a different 17 year old
because you have a child coming.
- Something you're going to know
you're going to have to raise a child.
- So for every single
person that's watching.
I think practicality or settling,
because they're cousins
they don't have to be the exact same thing
but their cousins in them,
comes at different times.
I do think.
Look I know a lot of 40 to 50 year olds
that are still living in outer space
and dreaming.
And I think there's diminishing returns
at some level around that.
Especially if it hasn't happened already.
Unless their happy.
- But isn't practicality
the thing you dip into
because you can be living your dream.
Pretending live in fantasy land
but you've got to pay rent.
You've got to eat.
And sometimes that
actually dip into real life.
Is what motivates your passion.
Those two things they.
- That's Casey's favorite answer, right?
- Is it?
Casey's favorite answer,
I think he said in the show was
do something you hate.
to realize how much you
want to do something else.
Go wash dishes like he did.
- Unbelievably motivating.
- What the thing you did the most,
in your life,
what's the thing you did the most
that you hated?
- I went to school for fucking ever.
- Yeah.
- Forever.
- From six to 18 I hated life.
- That's why I love it so much now.
I'm not in fucking English class.
- Seriously we got to put a
filter on this culturally.
This is a real thing.
People are going to college
for all the wrong reasons.
Do you need a piece a paper
that says you have to have
a piece of paper to cut
someone open?
I want my doctor to be certified.
I want my airline pilot to be certified.
Anything else?
Why, maybe there's some value there.
If you're exploring.
If you're trying to figure your shit out
schools a reasonable thing.
The average person graduates
college at $35,200 in debt.
That's the average.
So for everybody who
graduates with only 10 grand,
there's someone who graduates with 50.
That's bullshit.
- Preaching.
I've been pumping out some serious content
around this issue.
So the answer is it
different for everybody.
Some people get practical at 16.
They don't have that risk tolerance.
- Or you figure it out.
There is a practicality
when you figure out
what you want to do.
Then you got to get to work.
Would you call that practical?
- Here's what I truly think.
I think shit is really hitting the fan.
The Internet,
I don't know if you've heard of it
obviously all of us have,
it's only 20 years old.
I know it's been around for a long time.
I know there's nerds that say, I know.
I mean when Windows 95 came out,
normal people started
going on the Internet
we are 20 years into this thing.
This thing is fundamentally
the biggest culture shift
of our time.
- For sure.
- They've changed everything.
We're just starting
and all the rules need to be thought about
in a very aggressive way
because there's so many
alternatives to the way
that we always thought.
The amount of people that go to college
Because that's what their parents want
because their parents were
sold on the propaganda
of college before that--
- It's literally about
their ego most of the time.
- 100 percent.
- My son went to this,
went to this.
- I made a shirt called Shmarvard.
That is literally my
number one selling t-shirt.
It's not even close.
- I saw it.
Is it blue?
- Yes, yes.
India?
- I didn't know the story that's good.
- [Voiceover] Isham asked,
"would you say the "T" in
timing is way more important
"than the "T" in talent?"
- Not even close for me.
- Uh, what?
- No, Isham.
- Isham.
- Do not disrespect this show.
- The show.
Timing is a talent in itself.
- In 2006 after carefully
watching YouTube for five months,
I just got lucky I decided to go on it.
Luck timing for me.
Oh weird.
No, no, no.
There was talent
and understanding
That this platform was
going to be meaningful.
You got so lucky with
your timing with YouTube.
Bullshit motherfucker.
I fucking paid attention.
It's going there.
There was talent in understanding
that this was going to be important
and I put time and effort to learn it.
Weird here I am.
Weird here's YouTube.
Timing is a talent in itself.
One of the most important talents, Chase.
- For sure.
It's Isham?
- Yes.
- Isham talent, cultivate it.
What are you good at?
What do you love?
That's what matters.
Timing I guess it matters in the sake
of getting hit by a bus.
But that's about it.
- Too many people think
you were at the right place
at the right time.
Let me tell you something Isham
and everybody else,
if the internet didn't come along,
I would have 17,000
liquor stores right now.
Would've been a great timing
for bricks and mortar.
Talent trumps all.
It is the absolute variable.
Period end of story.
- Hardwork's in there.
I love the hustle,
I love the hustle.
- Talent without hard work is pretty much.
- I do think talent is a variable.
- Timing it's not even close.
- Timing, but I
will say this.
If I work 16 hours a day
on my basketball game
I am not going to be an NBA player.
- For sure.
- Talent is the variable.
What hard work does is
it maximizes that talent
of whatever you're deploy
that hard work against.
- Isham I'm sorry about that, real.
- Did Isham ask it that way
end that rant.
- [India] He just said it in a weird way.
He said is the "T" in
timing more important
than the "T" in talent.
- That's the question.
Very nice of you trying to save Isham.
- No, no.
Just wanted to make sure
that was the actual question.
- Timing is a talent in itself.
Somebody is going to be like
Gary you were so lucky with
the timing of virtual reality
and 360 video.
No, no, no.
I had talent in figuring
out that this is about to be
the time for that thing to pop.
What's going on with
you guys in 360 video.
I mean 360 fucking video.
- I know.
We're playing around with it.
You can imagine being in
an education environment
where you can look around
and see everything at your will.
- Educational.
- That's next level.
- India.
- [India] Last one.
- Last one.
- From Corey
- Do you do five?
- Five's my favorite number.
- [Voiceover] Corey asked
Star Wars or Star Trek?
Or both?
- Star Wars,
not Star Trek.
- Star Wars not Star Trek, too.
How old are you?
- I'm 43.
- That makes sense.
I'm 39.
That's like the golden year.
If you were 52,
if we asked Peter he
might've been Star Trek.
Because Star Trek was earlier.
There's not a lot of 32
to 40 year old Star Trek.
There is a fun pocket of maybe 35 to 42.
There is a funny pocket of 30 to 35
where they was Star
Trek The Next Generation
during a lull of Star Wars
where it popped a little bit.
Quick side question of
the day get in there
Star Trek or Star Wars and your age.
I think people will realize.
- That's a good question of the day.
- I think Star Trek is really 48 and above
and then a weird little
pocket of 30 to 32.
- There's a couple of people
who are really Star Trek.
It's an interesting cultural thing,
but Star Wars.
- Do you love star Wars?
- I don't.
I don't freak out over fantasy.
Like Game of Thrones.
- Star Wars is the only thing I go for.
Like I'll go see Star Wars opening night.
- For sure.
That's a cultural thing.
For me it was a big thing
because the Jets, Star Wars,
these were some of the few
pillars that made me an American
when I first came.
- I have all of the
Star Wars action figures
and all their guns.
- Do you still have them?
- Yeah they're worth some money.
- No they're not send them to me.
(laughter)
- Star Wars.
Chase you get the floor for
the last couple seconds.
Go on a little rant.
Then the question of the day.
You get to ask the Vayner
Nation any question,
they'll leave comments.
I would real think about
using this as a focus group.
Do your thing, nope.
I can not help you, nope.
On the spot I'm enjoying
this tremendously.
Yeah look at this very similar.
Stop stalling
and ask the question.
- Damn you know me.
- I know everybody, Chase.
I know everybody.
- You score very high on the
emotional intelligence deal.
- Chase do you know what
I think of all time.
- Time, 11?
- No, no, yes.
In that context.
I actually have in my will have put
that when humans figure
out how to measure EQ,
I want to be dug up
and tested because I
truly think I'm all time.
Go ahead.
- I think you score very high.
- All time.
(laughter)
- What you're asking me to
do to ask the Vayner Nation
a question that I want to use
basically use them as a focus group.
- You don't have to do
anything you want.
I just at this point want you
to ask any fucking question.
(laughter)
Ask them if you think
the Mets are going to win
the World Series.
Come up with something.
What's their favorite color?
I don't give a shit at this point.
- Talk to me about this
is about virtual reality.
What I want to know about virtual reality
is how likely do you think it is
that it will change the
game in the next 24 months.
Is it going to be everywhere
in the next 24 months.
Is it like so many things
that they thought were going
to happen.
Is it going to get punted
down like Connected Home.
Everyone thought Connected Home.
- By the year 2010.
- All that shit got punted way downfield.
What about virtual reality?
Is it happening now
or is it going to get the punt?
- That's a great question because
I talk a lot about timing.
Practicality around when these things pop.
We know it's not going to happen.
Is it 24 months or less?
Or is it more like a seven
years from now it's really
going to happen?
- There you go.
- Chase thanks for being on the show, man.
- Much respect.
- Continued success.
- Thank you very much.
Bye people.
- You keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them.
(uptempo music)